hey guys it's sarah hyland and i play
kelly in buzzfeed's new feature film my
fake boyfriend and today
we're playing a game of first
first bad date experience
unfortunately for me
i have not been on a lot of dates
i mean i guess my first bad date was my
first date
i was like 13.
[Laughter]
we went to see along came polly
loved it
but um
i had my first makeout
and
it was
very wet and very dry all at the same
time do not ask me how it just was and
then i was just like
um first time you were star struck
i was about five
and i
uh was
in love with josh from clueless
and um i was just absolutely and utterly
in love with him and like my
five-year-old self thought that we were
going to get married one day like truly
like what um first song you put on to
get you in the partying mood oh
and yeah no um
probably something by dua lipa or
like cardi b or lizzo
first celebrity crush jtt
who didn't love a jtt
first time performing live i was about
three it was a play my dad was doing
and i think they randomly were just like
hey do you want to stand up here and i
said yes
first time producing a feature film um i
think i was 22.
um and it was called see you in valhalla
and
[Music]
yeah we we made a feature film for like
no money at all it was crazy but it was
so much fun
and now i like producing a lot
this is fun first time doing voice
acting oh my gosh
i don't remember how old i was but i was
like the daniels girl for a really long
time
you remember like in the animal kingdom
kids rule
that was me
first behind the scenes memory that pops
into your head when you think of modern
family
probably just like sophia
yelling out pepsi to no one specifically
and
then like within five seconds of pepsi
just shows up and you're just like how's
it
magic
like how does she do this
i don't understand
i asked for a water like an hour ago i
still haven't gotten one
um
first pet
he was a cat who acted like a dog
and
his name was fred
he was
the best cat the only cat i've ever had
first food stop when you're back in new
york oh bleeker street pizza
obviously
last question first untrue rumor you
heard about yourself probably like a
pregnant or like she's engaged and julie
bowen doesn't
approve
i feel like that might have been the
first one pregnancy like everything it's
been a lot
it's been fun buzzfeed thank you so much
go watch my fake boyfriend